welcome to the town of asbestos callback
these days asbestos is a word with a
sense of Doom attached to it but when
this mine was opened in the late 19th
century that really wasn't the case
which is why they named the town after
it this pit just here was the biggest
asbestos mine in the world asbestos is a
mineral easily mined in pits like this
it can be turned into strong cheap fire
resistant insulation and it was used in
a huge number of building projects in
the 20th century either as big
insulation blocks or in ceiling tiles or
just sprayed on as cladding it was a
miracle substance it could even be woven
into clothing like military uniforms or
firefighters gloves the catch is that
it's made up of microscopic little
fibrous crystals
if you break us best just drop it
sandpaper it turn it into insulation
spray it around those little fibers get
into the air and build up in people's
lungs decades later people who have
worked with asbestos or live near an
asbestos mine they tend to develop a
particularly nasty type of cancer called
mesothelioma any exposure to asbestos
fibers however small can be dangerous
and in this town though sometimes so
much asbestos dust in the air but kids
could write their names in it when it's
settled
we know all that now so why haven't they
changed the name in 2006 the town's then
mayor trying to change it but the idea
was voted down and I wanted to find out
why but no one from the town wanted to
talk to me I emailed quite a few places
the local government the Historical
Society everyone either said no they
weren't interested or just didn't reply
they were polite of course they're
Canadian but it wasn't for them and it
took me perhaps a little bit too long to
realize why the name attracts people
like me and viewers like you
I knew this video was going to be titled
a town called asbestos right away it's
the obvious title it's got a ring to it
which is why there's already a five-part
series on YouTube from 2011 called
exactly that put together by a
researcher who spent years with this
town
she turned her PhD into a book also
titled a town called asbestos vice.com
published a series by a German
photojournalist titled a town called
asbestos all the time
people turn up here to document the town
with the name some of them like this
author are thorough and sympathetic and
take decades of history into account
some aren't some just set up a camera by
the mine overlook could turn up for a
couple of hours and film something
others don't even visit they just make
fun of them from the other side of the
world why because the town's name is
asbestos how do you feel about the name
why don't you change it they've answered
these same questions for years and I
suspect they're very very tired of it
the clearest answer that I've found is
from an interview in The Globe and Mail
in 2016
Gilliam Tessier vice president of a
local Chamber of Commerce said asbestos
was our lives
it was our heritage and I think that's
the key to why this town is still called
asbestos because yes for most of the
world the name is alarming but here
that's tempered with the fact that this
mine like a coal miner a gold mine it
was how people made their living
lots of people worked in the mine and
their parents and their grandparents and
their great-grandparents it was part of
their identity a mineral that the world
wanted to use it was made right here by
them and it saved lives and it really
was something to be proud of asbestos
and this mine was defended by the folks
who worked here in 97 just after France
bandhas wrestles four men from this town
four of the luckier ones ran the Paris
marathon and they were congratulated in
a statement in Canada's Parliament for
showing but the risks weren't that great
because the risks were drastically
downplayed by management and by
government even after the world at large
agreed how dangerous asbestos is
economics and the desire for profit
meant that it was still mined for
decades here this mine only closed in
2012 it's only been a few years maybe
the name will change if I need to stop
jerks like me coming along and going oh
look at this place but not just yet dr.
jessica van Horseman's book is the
definitive history of the town and the
mine a lot of this video is based on it
and I thoroughly recommend it
you